let's look at the events of second week  of embryonic development after a  successful fertilization at day seven  the embryo is known as a blastocyst  which has two layers the outer  trophoblast and the inner cell mass  which has the stem cells now at day  eight the trophoblast is now subdivided  into cytotrophoblast and the cincio  trophoblast and the inner cell mass  further divides into epiblast and  hypoblast a amniotic cavity starts  forming at this particular day also at  day 10 you can find a primitive yolk sac  which is forming  at this time lacunar networks start to  form  at day 12 the implantation is kind of  complete and the lacunar network is now  developing and forming connection  between  the mother and the embryo and this is  how the second week is done subscribe  for more